following yesterday's insurgents in d.c
many of you have been saying your kids
are asking questions about what exactly
happened it's just the latest in a long
list of issues and events that we're all
trying to process
orco mana is in our newsroom with more
on how to approach
discussing these topics with your
children orca
yeah well brian it's safe to say that
we've all seen our country and our
community go through some really tough
times lately
and our kids are seeing everything
unfold experts say parents and
educators need to create an open
dialogue
families across las vegas are still
processing wednesday's riot at the u.s
capitol it was just shocking like many
kids 13 year old skyler soto had
questions
i asked why was this happening
why are they doing this and it's not the
first time
children have seen so much in just the
past few years
from the murder of george floyd and the
racial reckoning that followed to the
intense political controversies to the
coronavirus pandemic
our kids just want to know why questions
like this have become
commonplace as a parent you're answering
a lot more questions than we did when we
were kids so you want to be proactive
experts say
kids often know more than you think they
do so sheltering them is not a good idea
but how you tackle these topics is key
for younger kids keep your emotions in
check and for pre-teens keep politics
and rhetoric
out of the conversation you want to
actually
allow them to come to their own
conclusions so you want to
have an open discussion ccsd even saying
as educators part of their
responsibility is to allow students to
have these conversations in a safe
environment
that's something teacher ryan from alts
has been doing
i let them speak their mind let them
have their feelings come out
sometimes i'll try to guide the
discussion it's all about being a
sounding board
parents need to communicate with their
kids
experts add it's not uncommon for major
events to lead to anxiety for some kids
and if you don't think
you can handle it on your own you should
reach out for professional help
in the newsroom tonight orca mana 8 news
now